I on the highway in train
with a heart that
was out of my
CH so
now can't keep
up if I don't
get
know can't get
it I can't get it can't it I can't
it it I can't
it you're only going to see what I want
you to see and I have quite a lot to
show you is going
on
everything getting harder to find
everybody jumping out of mind everybody
going out of the skin see we get to the
end but that's where we begin you feel
it mannequin and we breaking the
breaking out and we breaking the codes
similar to the Jack who stole to the
depths in your W so you take explos to
get it out
no time to
rest just do your
best what you he is not a
test I'm only here to make you we're
only here to make you we're only here to
make you we're only here to make you go
go